Trascrizione: Sabrina Rizzello
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Non ve lo aspettavate questa, eh?
Come impariamo?
Proviamo a parlarne insieme,
ricordandoci oggi gli studi
di un antropologo inglese,
Gregory Bateson,
il quale ci ha parlato
dei "livelli di apprendimento".
Partiamo con l'apprendimento uno:
raccogliere informazioni, e aggregarle.
L'apprendimento uno
è forse il più semplice,
e avviene attraverso
due livelli principali:
la scuola e gli adulti di riferimento.
Impariamo, ad esempio, dagli adulti
a dire: "Grazie, buongiorno, buonasera".
Impariamo che nella strada
si passa con il verde,
e ci si ferma con il rosso.
Non in tutte le città, a dire il vero;
ma questo è un altro discorso.
A scuola poi impariamo
altre "informazioni uno":
due più due fa quattro;
impariamo la data di nascita di Leopardi;
impariamo il teorema di Pitagora.
Poi, noi stratificano
queste informazioni uno;
e ad un certo punto
il cervello fa uno scatto,
comincia a trattenere alcune
e altre invece non gli interessano più,
le lascia andare.
Ne ho avuta una prova
stamattina verso le sei,
quando ho accompagnato
una delle mie figlie
a prendere il treno
insieme a delle amiche,
per raggiungere un'altra amica
in una ridente località
marittima della Romagna.
Ho provato a verificare
se i suoi apprendimenti uno
fossero tutti presenti
per godersi la vacanza.
Allora le ho chiesto:
sai qual è l'indirizzo
dell'appartamento che devi raggiungere?
Risposta: Boh.
Ti sei informata con le tue amiche,
e preparata per preparare i pasti?
Boh.
Hai un'idea dell'orario
di ritorno di martedì?
Risposta? Pubblico: Boh.
Bravissimi.
Vedete che avete imparato anche voi
con l'apprendimento uno.
Quarta e ultima domanda:
stasera vai in discoteca?
Assolutamente sì:
abbiamo il tavolo prenotato,
il pr si chiama DJ Devo,
l'ho già spoilerato su Instagram.
Le informazioni uno che le servono
le erano molto chiare.
Dopo un po' di tempo
che il cervello stratifica informazioni,
è in grado di fare
il cosiddetto "salto di livello"
e andare all'apprendimento due,
imparare a imparare.
Questo salto di livello,
di cui abbiamo parlato
anche nell'introduzione,
permette all'uomo di innovare.
Di scoprire.
Di essere creativo.
Un esempio molto classico
è ciò che è successo all'Apollo 13:
"Houston, abbiamo un -"
Pubblico: Problema!
Le informazioni uno non funzionano,
c'è stato un guasto nella navicella.
Tutto era stato perfettamente preparato,
[però] non funziona.
Gli ingegneri di terra
ricevono i materiali
presenti nella navicella,
e sviluppano un apprendimento due:
inventano un ossigenatore.
Poi mandano le informazioni,
che dal due ritornano uno,
agli astronauti,
permettendo loro
di tornare vivi sulla Terra.
Ma non solo per gli ingegneri aerospaziali
è presente l'apprendimento due:
anche per noi.
Ad esempio, molti anni fa -
sono diversamente giovane,
per cui ho fatto in tempo a vivere
in un'epoca pre Google Maps -
mi sono perso in una città italiana.
Meravigliosa, di mare.
Non trovando il porto dove dovevo recarmi
per imbarcarmi sul traghetto,
ho avuto un momento di smarrimento,
e ho deciso di applicare
l'informazione uno
che mi aveva insegnato mia nonna:
chiedi a un passante.
Quindi ho fermato un passante,
e gli ho chiesto se gentilmente
poteva dirmi dov'era il porto.
Questa persona mi ha,
con grandissima gentilezza, detto così:
"Vede quella via in fondo a sinistra?"
"Sì, certo."
"La prende, la percorre
per due chilometri, sempre dritto.
Arriverà proprio sulla via del Mare,
e guardi, a sinistra c'è il porto."
Lei è già arrivato":
E io ho chiesto: "Però, nella via
che lei mi sta indicando
c'è un cartello con scritto
'Divieto di Transito'.
Io non ci posso andare."
Ah, sì, ma guardi,
noi qua tutti sappiamo
che ci possiamo andare lo stesso."
La domanda è: Voi ci sareste andati?
E l'altra domanda è: io ci sono andato?
No, non ci sono andato,
perché ho il disturbo
emiliano di personalità,
quindi mi fido troppo
delle informazioni uno,
e faccio fatica a passare
le informazioni due.
Però, ho comunque imparato
che devo fidarmi di più delle persone
e meno solo delle informazioni uno.
Quindi posso parlare
di un altro livello di apprendimento,
l'apprendimento zero.
Quello di cui si parla meno.
L'"apprendimento zero"
è imparare senza che nessuno insegni.
È l'apprendimento implicito:
quello che gli scienziati chiamano
"il nostro sistema dotato di memoria",
il cervello,
ne è pieno.
Nessuno ci insegna a camminare;
nessuno ci insegna a piangere;
nessuno ci insegna a respirare.
Noi lo sappiamo fare, anche correre.
E se precocemente veniamo
a contatto con l'acqua,
anche nuotare.
L'"apprendimento zero"
è quello che ci ricorda
che noi siamo nativi,
che dobbiamo rispettare
le leggi biologiche
perché parlano in noi,
che siamo connessi al pianeta.
E mai come oggi c'è bisogno
di ricordarcelo.
È importante l'apprendimento zero?
Assolutamente sì.
Ce lo ricorda tutti i giorni
il nostro corpo.
Se abbiamo paura, ci tremano le gambe;
se ci innamoriamo,
batte diversamente il cuore;
se qualcosa ci commuove,
i nostri occhi perdono un liquido.
Si chiamano lacrime.
E l'apprendimento zero
è una di quelle forme vibranti
del nostro sapere,
che ci permette di parlare
dell'ultimo livello di apprendimento,
il più complesso:
l'apprendimento tre.
L'uomo impara attraverso
lo stupore e la meraviglia.
E le cose che, nell'umanità,
più possono promuovere
lo stupore e la meraviglia
sono l'arte e la bellezza.
Più noi siamo in grado di intercettare,
di andare incontro all'arte e la bellezza,
più noi viviamo degli apprendimenti tre.
Durante un apprendimento tre,
noi scopriamo che la vita è sacra.
Ma c'è qualcos'altro
che può proporci l'apprendimento tre,
e sono piccolissime cose
della nostra quotidianità,
purché il nostro occhio sia in grado
di guardarle con meraviglia.
Nella più grande delle piccolezze,
può esserci la più grande forma
di sacralità della vita stessa.
Il poeta Erri De Luca
è in grado di raccontarci
che cos'è un apprendimento tre
con questa poesia, che ora vi leggo.
"Considero valore ogni forma di vita:
la neve, la fragola, la mosca.
Considero valore il regno minerale,
l'assemblea delle stelle.
Considero valore il vino
finché dura il pasto.
Un sorriso involontario,
la stanchezza di chi non si è risparmiato,
due vecchi che si amano.
Considero valore tutte le ferite.
Considero valore risparmiare acqua,
riparare un paio di scarpe,
tacere in tempo, accorrere a un grido,
provare gratitudine
senza ricordare di ché.
Considero valore il viaggio del vagabondo,
la clausura della monaca,
la pazienza del condannato,
qualunque colpa sia.
Considero valore l'uso del verbo amare,
e l'ipotesi che esista un Creatore"
Ebbene, per concludere, una storia,
Una storia vera.
Dieci anni fa, in questa terra
c'è stato il terremoto.
E racconto la storia
di un amico, di un ragazzo,
che 10 anni fa si trova
in una condizione particolare,
come tutti noi.
Si trova in mezzo
a tutte le persone intorno a lui
che hanno perso la casa e il lavoro;
e impara un apprendimento uno,
una parola nuova: inagibile.
Ed è disperato, perché i suoi genitori
sono già un po' avanti con l'età;
e nel passare dei giorni,
mentre dormono in macchina,
vorrebbe dar loro una tenda per dormire,
ma non la trova: le hanno comprate tutte.
Ma non c'è stata solo l'onda
della terra, dieci anni fa;
c'è stata un'altra onda,
l'onda della solidarietà.
Organizzata - dalle associazioni,
dalla Protezione Civile -
e disorganizzata:
un'onda umana di persone
che hanno portato delle cose,
come cibo, vicinanza, materiali, progetti,
e questa.
Quel ragazzo riceve quella tenda in dono,
E può finalmente mettere
al riparo i suoi genitori.
Poi, l'emergenza passa.
Ricostruiamo, siamo operosi:
siamo emiliani.
Abbiamo ricevuto tantissimo
con tenacia e speranza.
Passano dieci anni, quel ragazzo
ha dimenticato la tenda nel garage,
ed è diventato un uomo.
E nel Marzo di quest'anno,
una notte non riesce a dormire.
I suoi apprendimenti zero sono alterati.
Il cuore batte molto forte, non sa perché.
Le sue gambe vogliono muoversi,
e non sa perché.
Sa solo che a un certo punto,
nel cuore della notte,
si mette in viaggio, fa 1500 chilometri,
arriva al confine
più estremo della Polonia.
E vede centinaia,
forse migliaia di persone
che sono come lui dieci anni fa:
non hanno casa, non hanno lavoro,
forse non hanno più la libertà.
E vede, ancora una volta,
l'onda della solidarietà,
e lui ne fa parte.
Cammina, cerca, non sa cosa cerca.
Ancora non lo sa.
Poi trova una donna per caso,
con due bambini.
Si guardano:
e lui capisce, in quel momento,
che a quella donna deve dare questa tenda.
E capisce solo in quel momento
perché lui è lì,
perché in quel momento,
mentre dona la tenda e si abbracciano,
sente sciogliersi dentro di lui
il nodo della gratitudine,
la morsa della gratitudine,
che sciogliendosi diventa
l'abbraccio della comunità,
diventa il non sentirsi soli.
Diventa una forma molto raffinata
di apprendimento tre;
e in quel momento quelle due persone,
che non sanno nemmeno i loro nomi,
e non hanno un linguaggio comune,
imparano la gratitudine, la vicinanza,
e che la vita è sacra.
Grazie.
(Applausi)